okay let's see what happens in this game
welcome to this video el jugador the
player right I didn't play many hit on
words in Spanish but I know that the
translation here is the player 7 let's
see if I can get back above 2400 again
here how's you got the warrior okay I'm
going back with back to my old line so
he's got two thousand five hundred and
five minute and all other ratings are
crap right yeah sure okay this will get
a report no matter what sorry I'm just
fed up with this crap you don't have one
two thousand three minute or in bullet
and have 25 min to 450 in five minutes
this is just anyway okay let's see what
I can do here maybe is playing so slow
that i can do something on time right
cleared yes sir it takes the same five
seconds for every freakin move everybody
plays G for you or 93 after the second
ya know it takes even longer what
happens now trying to restart the engine
look up the theory in a book what are
you doing
okay this I will definitely play on time
to the very end I don't believe this
account one bit one bit okay I should
have taken first anyway we'll see what
happens ok now let's take it
at times very important in this game
because it takes too long here to
reproduce the engine moves so I will try
to do something on time here this is one
reason why I chose this chick or in line
I've played that a million times and
it's and at least I can play all those
moves very quickly
we don't know what people get out of
this check always playing always playing
quickly maybe he recognized that he has
to has to speed up huh okay um Knight g4
maybe I'd see I'm probably good back to
f4 huh doesn't help much for me I mean
no it takes it it's quite surprising no
Queen age 8 is coming still a very very
weird account I mean I mean it plays
this very bad here so it cannot be a
computer but the whole account is
totally fishy so okay we should over to
be six I guess
so let's see Queen edge to war tweenage
for Queen age for maybe I'm able to see
protected Queen you 10 th for cleen you
won my hair Queenie one could be now it
could be annoying ok but night f5 it's
not a threat if I check here and I've
got night you three I ok this is this
isn't this isn't clear at all so I just
go back here so i can take here on this
one taking g3 and deform right here i
can check check and check check and let
Shaq Goodwin stuff
q check check
Scott Queen a 6 may be here threatening
bishop divine resigns yeah I don't know
okay maybe I was a bit quick with with
the computer with the cheating claim but
I simply you know this is not this is
not a proper account you don't have
eighteen seventy and three minutes yeah
with a maximum of two thousand or one
minute 1900 ok I just 18 games I know
but this is this is a rating that
someone within over the word rating of
1800 ah 1,900 can get in 2440 and five
minutes is it's usually indicative of a
strong feeder master I MGM yeah and I
simply don't believe stuff like that and
then you have the very weird game here
where he takes ages for normal moves I
mean so okay here ya nite nite f1 okay
five seconds at age two took a very long
time okay I don't know you can maybe
think about g4 93-yard yeah I don't know
and this is also kind of normal that
simply don't believe how this
the spend time and everything how that
how that worked out it was really
strange yeah maybe it's a cow sharing
yeah you sometimes have that but that
you have a strong and weak player
playing on the same account and this is
leading to two things but anyway um if
you look at the game I think why does
slightly better in this position and he
um step by step with this I think with
what happened to you have to f4 sorry
after age 4chan yeah the trade i think
is questionable probably would have won
and and after this I'm I'm better I
could have actually checked already
there on a one Jack you should do one
night gr4 yeah this is pretty strong I'm
threatening stuff him this is the chat
chat engines line and the point is that
at the end this is hanging yeah this is
this move no it's very strange move okay
now it's clear that no engine played
this game yeah but I simply don't see
this player getting to 24 40 with the
game like with games like that being
played I don't know very strange I don't
know what to do with this video but
should even should even that publish
that it's very weird but I just don't
don't understand some accounts yeah you
cannot seriously be 1900 in one in one
time control and to 450 in the other
yeah also note that yeah this all-time
high in three minute which is just 2002
currently is 1800 there was from 2014
and the all-time high in five minute is
from yesterday so neither there was a um
yeah someone took took over this account
yeah this is possible was something
fishy is other fish something other
fishy differently fishy let's say it's
going on it's bad english okay um I hope
it was still somewhat interesting to
watch thanks for watching